quite straightforward actually no not
here yeah here we we get checked so
Captain King E3 give a check first yeah
we give a check and then we go either
e4b4 or rookie one yeah and
yeah otherwise
otherwise if you play Roxy a check
you're just looking before and would be
five yeah Magnus is not hiding his
feelings here he knows uh this one's
gone on longer than it needed to yeah
he's I guess he is a bit miffed that he
is being actually questioned about this
it's probably been 20 years since he's
been asked this question yeah and there
we go if we do finally see a handshake
resigns
uh he's back uh Magnus now Peter very
much so he's on plus two
he will be tied for second with Wesley
uh a full point still a full point
behind Park uh
but three rounds to go he definitely has
has gathered some steam